thanks Tad well it's a party neighbors
say they are not invited to but they're
forced to deal with we're talking about
a vacation rental which is in a historic
Las Vegas neighborhood people there are
telling us here at Channel 8 when they
ask the homeowner about it they face
harassment eight news now reporter Ryan
maffey joining us live in studio with
the neighbors experiences right yeah
Brian Denise the historic Rancho Sereno
neighborhood it's described as quiet
with neighbors that mostly keep to
themselves but it's the guess at this
house that neighbors say Bring the Noise
and the homeowner who brings the threats
saved
it takes the neighborhood out of the
neighborhood Daniel Bailey says he hears
it even two doors down however we can
have a party to have it going on that
house is popping every weekend and those
across the street say street parking
becomes brutal I mean it's kind of a
party house but Kelsey stagal and Thomas
Carter live directly next door to what's
advertised on short-term rental apps as
a stunning home with a private Oasis she
kept ringing and ringing and ringing the
doorbell but to this couple it's
anything but this homeowner they call a
harasser after they say concerns of the
loud parties are brought to her
attention she texted me like
10 times as vile things and then she
said stop texting me you're harassing me
text like this Carter shares with me I'm
gonna stop the Airbnb and sue you for
Millions for losing business because of
you Las Vegas city documents show two
code enforcement complaints regarding
noise at the rental over the past two
years a city representative said there
is a third one ongoing through business
licensing he's an attorney I'm calling
the bar on you and then the voicemails
look at your tattoos you look so bad you
are junk men junkie what the couple said
was received after the homeowner then
made complaints about the couple's
barking dogs one of several calls they
say are lies even when Amazon comes I'm
just like who am I gonna have to go talk
to because I think it's going to be
animal control or code enforcement or
something from one of her uh bogus
complaints that she calls in
the couple sees no solution in sight but
they also don't see themselves leaving
despite this text saying your stay here
is gonna be Hell she's the one who has a
business here like we have more of a
right to be here than she does
now I did make an effort to get the
homeowners out of the story but the
brief phone call I had with her
yesterday ended with her hanging up and
I did get a follow-up text from her
where she denies all these accusations
the neighbors are giving but that was
before she threatened to sue us if we
were to continue with the story
all right so moving forward from this
Ryan there's all these complaints what
happens now what happens next so I asked
the business Licensing Bureau about that
they told me it depends on them actually
saying there is a violation once they do
250 for the first one 500 for the ones
right after that uh but from there on
it's literally like losing your license
altogether what do you got to do for
that they said that varies so we don't
really have a four set thing for that
but she does or actually if you look at
the ordinances specifically for
short-term rentals parking on the street
large parties excessive noise it's all
against it okay good work man thank you
thank you